bill slapping new sanctions on Russia is
headed in this morning to the
President's desk the Senate voted 98 to
2 yesterday to punish Russia Iran and
North Korea for various violations
it puts Congress on a collision course
with President Trump over Russia the
White House has not said whether the
president will sign this bill
communications director Anthony scare
Moochie said yesterday quote he may sign
the sanctions exactly the way they are
or he may veto the sanctions and
negotiate an even tougher deal against
the Russians well this morning Russia
announced how it plans to retaliate
Charlie d'Agata is in Moscow with the
payback from the Kremlin charlie good
morning good morning the announcement
was released in a statement by the
Russian Foreign Ministry that it was
reducing the number of US diplomats to
the same levels of Russian diplomats in
the United States it was seizing
warehouse facilities here and a vacation
facility outside the capital now we
contacted the US Embassy here in Moscow
who confirmed that they received the
notification and ambassador John Tefft
expressed his strong disappointment and
protest at the decision now though this
can be seen as a tit-for-tat for the
expulsion of a number of Russian
diplomats from the United States back in
December the foreign ministry explicitly
said that this was in response for the
new sanctions package that's making its
way through Washington DC at the moment
yesterday Russian President Vladimir
Putin called the new sanctions illegal
under international law and a blatant
move by the United States to promote its
own economic interests overseas he also
warned that Russia would respond to
those sanctions that's including
warnings today that if the United States
expels more Russian diplomats the
government here will respond in kind
Charlie Charlie d'Agata reporting from
Moscow here